The next key concept to consider is design documentation. If we're talking about
the software design of large systems, the systems are likely to be complex and
the scale and complexity beg for having good design documentation.
If you've invested all that energy in developing the system, it's likely that
that system is going to around for a while and is going to be under maintenance,
maybe by people that were different than the original designers. And having some
form of written communication can be a big help. Different kinds of methods,
different kinds of applications, require different kinds of documentation.
Those may range from formal, multi-volume documents,
to scribbled notes or, or slides in, that are used for presentations